[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hungary is like a low-calorie version of
russia do they have corruption yes but
it doesn't quite reach the level of
russia is it an authoritarian government
yes increasingly so but they do not go
quite as far as poisoning political
opponents with novichok it's still a
country in the european union which is
to say with the most basic democratic
guarantees the president of hungary is
this man you see on the screen victor
orban putin's main ally in europe we
could say that orban is like the
annoying little brother of brussels
authoritarian ultra-conservative and
pro-putin what a combo and i know what
many of you are thinking this video
isn't going to be a pointless criticism
of our ban is it for some reason we get
a lot of comments accusing us of being
funded by george soros as everybody
knows orban is soros's arch enemy so
it's crystal clear surely this video is
funded by soros so that we show the
shamefulness of the hungarian president
right right side note have you ever
wondered why george soros is so well
known we'll tell you at the end of this
video and i am sorry to disappoint you
but in today's video we're not going to
insult orban very much let's focus on
the other side of hungary what are we
talking about we're talking about this
victor orban wins fourth consecutive
term as hungary's prime minister that's
right four consecutive electoral
victories viktor orban has been in power
for more than 12 years and every time he
goes to the polls he sweeps the floor
these latest elections those of 2022
have merit in this case almost all the
political parties join together in a
coalition to try to defeat him not only
has he won he's won by an absolute
majority again in other words if you
want to win elections get an orban in
your life and yes you did hear correctly
he won the elections as we have said
before hungary is like russia but low in
calories this means the elections are
relatively free true or bans party the
fidez has done some minor cheating but
you have to recognize reality for what
it is orban doesn't need to make up the
data he is really popular in his country
the question is why what is the secret
behind victor orban's success is there a
lesson we can learn from hungary and why
is george soros so well known around the
world today we're going to answer all of
these questions but first do you know
how you can actively support all of us
here at visualpolitik by joining our
patreon community not only will you be
contributing to keeping visualpolitik
going and you will also have access to
merchandising such as this t-shirt i'm
wearing it's not for sale the only way
to get it is by being part of our
community and that's not all we also
have a weekly bulletin the weekly
snapshot where we cover topics that we
don't have time to cover in the form of
videos as well as that we are also
uploading exclusive content for our
patrons for example we're about to
publish another video about hungary and
george soros where we delve into topics
that we do not have time to cover in
this one so you know if you don't want
to miss it i'll be waiting for you in
the visualpolitik community on patreon
and now let's take a look at some
history
[Music]
it's the economy stupid
are you familiar with a software called
archie cad if you work in anything
related to architecture surely you must
have used it at some point it is one of
the major pieces of software well it is
made in hungary with this example you
can get an idea of the hungarian economy
and its potential they have an important
activity sector an important
pharmaceutical sector and quite a lot of
industry
in other words it's not a wealthy
country like germany or sweden but it is
one of the most successful
post-communist economies almost at the
level of poland or the czech republic
however when orban came to power the
situation was very different hungary was
going through a huge economic crisis it
was 2010 and hungary was one of the
countries most affected by the great
financial crisis they had 11
unemployment the highest rate in europe
along with spain and 7 public deficit a
figure well above the requirements
demanded by europe
[Music]
it seemed orban had his work cut out for
him and what was his formula for saving
the economy well we could say that orban
did the opposite of what any centre-left
government would do let's say it clearly
orban is ultra-nationalist and does not
like people who come from abroad but
when it comes to money the tune changes
completely basically our band's strategy
has two pillars reducting to public
spending and rolling out the red carpet
for foreign capital and in this respect
hungary is a success story take a look
at this graph
[Music]
if you look closely you will see that
hungary is able to attract more money
from abroad than other countries like
germany or poland almost 75 of the
industrial investment in this country
comes from abroad and after orban came
to power this country has seen its
highest peaks the question is why what
does hungary have that other countries
don't have well the first answer is low
taxes if we think of countries with low
taxes ireland and luxembourg come to
mind but the truth is that hungary has
the lowest corporate tax rate in europe
here's a map
since 2017 hungarian companies pay a
basic 9 corporate income tax on top of
this must be added all kinds of subsidy
programs and tax deductions for example
if a company reinvests its profits in
hungarian startups it can save up to 80
in taxes if we add to this the fact that
hungary has a well-trained workforce and
relatively cheap wages it's easy to
understand why this country just keeps
attracting money from abroad to give you
an idea they are number two for
countries and the entire european union
for attracting investment from south
korea this does not mean that south
korea is the main investor in hungary
far from it but it serves as an example
to see how companies from countries as
remote as south korea bet on hungary
much more than on other countries put it
another way victor orban may be the
black sheep of the european family but
the results of his policies are not that
bad yes it's true orban may be the man
who would make greta thunderberg cry but
when companies that manufacture electric
cars choose a destination for their
factories they prefer hungary over many
other countries
that's right as of 2021 hungary is
putting itself at the forefront of the
electric vehicle industry at least in
europe check this out
sk innovation to build third battery
plant in hungary
bmw to build one billion euro electric
car factory in hungary
mercedes-benz will launch series
production of a purely electric vehicle
in hungary and i know what some of you
are thinking well hungary may be a
paradise for companies but does all this
money really reach the pockets of
ordinary hungarians well here the data
speaks for itself let me give you a
comparison in 2010 spain had an
unemployment rate of 19 while hungaries
was at 11 10 years later in 2020 spain
was at 15 while hungary was just above
four percent all this economic growth
has translated into more money for the
state and healthier accounts and what's
his money being spent on how do orban's
social policies work well we're going to
look at that right now
family values
here i know what many of you are
thinking victor orban is nothing but a
right-wing populist his entire economic
policy can be summed up in lowering
taxes and by doing that anyone could
keep the citizens happy well the truth
is he's actually not just a populist in
fact if we had to define hungary's tax
policy in any way it would be
anti-populism yes it's true companies
pay lower taxes than in any european
country but remember that companies do
not vote in this country almost all the
tax burden falls on the average citizen
how with the most unpopular tax that
exists vat and indirect taxes yes
hungary has the lowest corporate taxes
in europe but as far as indirect taxes
are concerned it's the opposite 27 i'm
not joking while most european countries
have a 21 tax rate hungary has a
whopping 27 you may criticize this
policy but we certainly cannot say that
it's an attempt to buy voters quite the
contrary
and the question is where does all this
money that is collected go what social
policies are there in hungary well this
is where we could talk about a kind of
conservative social democracy this is
where our ban shows his most traditional
side because almost all social policies
are oriented towards one single goal
having more children yeah that's right
the pension crisis is a problem all over
europe hungary included an orban's
recipe for avoiding democratic decline
is based on trying by all means possible
to get hungarians to start having
children
[Music]
for example since 2012 families with
four or more children do not pay income
tax that's right just like that zero
percent income tax and not only that
within the couple the mother who has
given birth to four children is tax-free
for life and what about families that
not have four children well for example
families with between three and four
children who buy a van can get a subsidy
of around seven thousand dollars
[Music]
in other words orban's policy is
extremely social yes it is true there
are social benefits conditional on
having children but it is assistance
that does reach the vast majority of
hungarians and don't think we're talking
about small changes here in 2019 the
so-called family protection programs
came to account for 4.8
of the entire hungarian gdp and the
question you're probably all wondering
now is are these policies working is
hungary really succeeding in ending the
demographic black hole well the answer
is a clear and resounding no take a look
at this graph
here you can see how the fertility rate
in hungary remains about the same with
or without birth control policies
hungarian women have an average of 1.6
children though i assume hungarians as a
whole are having quite a lot of fun in
other words the hungarian population is
still decreasing now that's good when it
comes to reducing inequality orban is a
genius take a look at this other graph
here you can see how the gap between
rich and poor is much more gentle in
hungary than in france or germany this
is not praise for orban by the way far
from it you know how little we like his
authoritarian way his lack of respect
for media freedom his attacks on
judicial independence or his behavior
during the ukrainian war but this is one
of the least known and least talks about
facets of hungarian politics
yes it's true you will never see orban
at a gay pride parade his rhetoric is
far from what would be understood as
social policy in any other country but
no one can deny that his government is
doing its best to help the most
disadvantaged families and that shows in
the elections and now i know what some
of you are thinking now visualpolitik is
putting orban on a pedestal this is just
like the conspiracy before but the other
way around could it be that the
hungarian government is paying them
under the table don't panic now we're
going to talk about the other side of
our bank the one that neither the
hungarian media nor the mainstream media
are mentioning check this out
[Applause]
[Music]
the man who created george soros
george soros is something like the elvis
presley of conspiracies there's no
conspiracy theory where soros doesn't
appear somewhere probably all of you
watching this video have heard him
mentioned at some point the question is
why is he so famous let me explain
george soros is a billionaire with a lot
of political clout yes that's true but
he is neither the richest person in the
world nor the most influential so why
does everyone know soros and not for
example the koch brothers the answer
lies in victor orban or rather in the
political strategist who created the
myth of victor orban but what does this
good man have to do with orban or soros
well you'll see orban's political career
has two strength stages from 1998 to
2002 victor orban was prime minister of
hungary in this case we would define him
as pro-free market but also
minded politician however in 2012 he
lost the elections for eight years he
was in the opposition and that's when he
hired the services of arthur finkelstein
arthur finkelstein was a political
communication consultant from the united
states or rather we could say that
arthur frenkelstein karl rove and lee
atwater are like the frank sinatra dean
martin and sammy davis jr of political
consulting true geniuses in the art of
winning elections
[Music]
[Applause]
well it was finkelstein who drew the new
image of orban a man of the people who
spends his weekends in the countryside
and drinks palinka but as those of you
have been following visualpolitik for a
long time already know to create a hero
in politics you have to create a villain
and who is the perfect villain for orban
none other than george soros although he
is not the richest investor in the world
by far he was born in hungary and
perhaps he is the richest hungarian in
the world and hatred against
millionaires is an electoral weapon as
old as impossible promises after this
the fact that he has always been
critical of orban and that he is jewish
which stirs the anti-semitic favor of
hungarians in other words soros was the
perfect villain and that explains
statements like this one
in speech hungary's auburn attacks enemy
who speculates with money
orban europe must not succumb to soros
network yikes by the way if you want to
understand more about the whole story of
who george soros is and how the myth was
created we will very soon release an
exclusive video on patreon where we
discuss this topic in depth so now you
have one more reason to join our
community on patreon but let's get back
to our story because there is another
ace that orban has up his sleeve another
special weapon for winning elections
outside hungary there are more than 2.4
million ethnic hulgarians that is in
romania slovakia and slovenia there are
many hungarian-speaking communities for
years orban has been giving them
passports so they can vote in elections
and all of them overwhelmingly vote for
orban's party the fidez
and you will say is this electoral
manipulation yes and no but nobody can
deny that our ban knows his voters very
well for example a time when everyone
seems to be very aware of the war in
ukraine orban has managed to make a move
that is as risky as it is accurate
breaking ranks with eu hungary ready to
pay for russian gas in rubles exactly
hungary is the eu country closest to
putin's russia from an ethical point of
view it's a real disgrace but in hungary
the average voter has voted with his
pocket and orban's closeness to putin
translates into cheaper gas and oil than
in any other european country at least
in the short term but what could happen
in the long term well this is where the
big problem of organomics comes in for
years budapest has been pushing the
boundaries with brussels and its stance
on the ukraine war could be the straw
that breaks the camel's back could the
european union sanction hungary let's
take another look at another chart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you look at the year 2004 there is a
substantial jump in the amount of money
coming into hungary so what happened in
2004 exactly hungary joined the european
union companies from the rest of europe
are the main investors in hungary in
other words orban's political and
economic success is tied to the european
union the question is what could happen
if the investment tap is suddenly cut
off to what extent could hungary's
stance on the ukrainian war be the
beginning of the end for the orban era
you can leave me your answers in the
comments below as always don't forget
that here on visualpolitik we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
this channel and hit the little bell
button down there so you don't miss any
of our updates remember that we also
have exclusive content and newsletter
and merchandising in our patreon
community if you like this video please
like it so we know and i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you